[Music]
man you know why this crowd's so excited
hockey in l.a right ladies and gentlemen
that's why you're excited
[Music]
that was sarcastic applause
no the la kings this is kind of exciting
they could win the stanley cup tomorrow
that's right
this is a strange thing officials in the
city of la have said if the la kings win
the stanley cup there are currently no
plans for a public celebration
yeah not to worry though laker fans have
offered to riot on their behalf
laker fans
they just want to rip some stuff up yeah
they don't care last night in la king's
fans taunted new jersey devils fans with
giant cardboard cutouts of jersey shore
characters
that's true
yeah sadly then new jersey tried to
taunt la fans with cardboard cutouts of
constant sunshine and legal marijuana
they got us pretty good
and both those things are perfect for
hockey
[Laughter]
they're kind of perfect for everything
yeah that's true they don't ruin
anything they don't
uh let's see what's going on in politics
bill clinton's out there stumping for
president obama
yeah
yesterday
thanks for voicing your approval
yesterday bill clinton told the crowd
remember me i'm the guy who gave you
four surplus budgets
yeah to which the crowd replied that's
not what we remember you for
that's not the first image that comes
right
budget guy yeah yeah
bill clinton uh spoke last night at a
fundraiser for president obama and i was
amazed at how quickly
clinton's speech was turned into a
campaign ad take a look
i don't think it's important
to re-elect the president i'm mitt
romney and i approve this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
message uh facebook's in the news did
you hear this facebook may change its
accounts policy and allow kids under 13
to join
under 13.
yeah when they heard this chinese
official said great now our workers will
never get anything done
mel gibson's father has filed for
divorce
did you hear that yeah
i hope his parents made it clear to mel
it's not his fault it's the jews
this was crazy i heard this according to
a new survey that just came out women
who have breast augmentation
have better sex yes
yeah
that's true
the study was conducted by men who
answer their wives surveys
here she comes okay just get out of here
this week the vatican denounced a nun
who declared her support for
masturbation she declared her support
for masturbation and they denounced her
yeah the vatican has ordered the nani to
seclusion which sounds pretty good to
her
don't know why i danced after that one
i just did now i mentioned this before a
big local story the los angeles kings
are up three games to none in the
stanley cup finals the kings
are on the verge
of winning their first stanley cup now
we've sent our camera crews out to
capture the madness because you can
imagine people in los angeles are going
crazy
[Music]
we take our hockey pretty seriously